uh deviant county is a game changer that
way the eagles thing is concerning
you're right they're already here we are
week one you know offensive line issues
you know where's al shawn jeffrey jalen
rieger's got a hurt shoulder mile
sanders has what a soft tissue lower
body injury right something like that so
we don't even know what we're going to
see for offensively from this football
team to start the year let alone they
got to play you know a front four with
washington the the football team who has
a pass rush let me just tell you i think
that's going to be fun to watch here and
now you got an offensive line who's got
some new parts and working together and
all that you know just seems to me that
right away it's going to be like hey
carson um remember how we ended off last
year uh we need you to pick it up right
there once again uh so we'll see where
that goes i i i think you dropped them a
little far but that that i get it
well i i initially dropped them one put
the graphic back up please i dropped
them one
and then i compared them to the team
that was next to them right i dropped
them behind the steelers and i put them
with the cowboys i got to put them
behind the cowboys with the vikings you
got to put them behind the vikings the
packers got them put behind the packers
that's how they fell for yeah when i
finally got down to the broncos i said
we're going to leave them there and that
was yesterday with the broncos now we'd
have to reshuffle
the deck with the broncos post von
miller yeah they're not staying at
number 15. regardless now if they beat
the titans next week on monday night
football to start the season then maybe
they stay at number 15 but going into
week one they're going to be lower than
15 they should be lower than 15 with von
miller done yeah i i don't disagree with
that that's a huge game changer and like
we talked about yeah it's a young
offense i don't expect them to just come
out firing all on all cylinders and drew
lock throwing for 350 yards and
everything working correctly i could see
them hitting some bumps in the road and
having to rely on that defense and yeah
like you said now it's no von miller and
we don't think bradley chubb is going to
be totally 100 dominant the guy we saw
our rookie year so i got questions there
too i get it
yeah and uh you're not moving that top
five though i mean that's that's going
to stay right no no the top five is not
changing and and i if anything i feel
more strongly about having the patriots
at number four i put him at number four
before we knew what cam newton was going
to be before we knew who the starting
quarterback was going to be the patriots
have handled all of the uncertainty and
all of the unpredictability so well we
already see that first glimmer of bill
belichick hacking the rules in a in a
legitimate way 53 players on the roster
no kickers on the active roster two
kickers on the practice squad the
ability to move two guys up every week
from the practice squad to the active
roster he's going to take and that's
just a
one glimpse
of all the rules that are out there all
the things you can do you know the
unlimited placement of players on ninja
preserve this year and they can return
after three weeks you can stash guys
left and right now they did that as a
counterbalance to the pandemic but it's
legitimate now you can stash guys three
weeks at a time that's something bill
belichick would love to do he's going to
take full advantage of no doubt he is
going to master the chaos and uh you
know we're making our playoff and super
bowl picks we always do it just in time
for the start of the season
i'm i'm trying to come up with a good
argument as to why the patriots aren't
going to represent the afc in the super
bowl and i just feel like this year
they're going to find a way to do it
especially with cam newton if he stays
healthy
i got him in the playoffs you know i'll
say that yup i got him winning a playoff
game too and and wouldn't be shocked
again there's things to like about this
football team and you know just what i
know now they're going to need some of
these young receivers to kind of you
know pop up and and establish themselves
and kill harry i heard he had a
tremendous camp uh up in new england he
seems to be like cam newton's go-to guy
we know that julian edelman's there you
know they got some young tight ends
they're going to have to have somebody
step up there a stable or running backs
but i just think between that and then
mcdaniels and belichick figuring out the
proper game plan and then you know all
the schematical tricks that they're
capable of behind a guy like cam newton
yeah i think the offense is going to be
more dangerous than last year that's for
sure and then defensively
you know again yeah i know dante
hightower is not there that hurts
there's some few players patrick chung
and this point of his career is not a
huge ball to this football team nobody
has more safeties on one single roster
than the new england patriots so they
can handle that
and they already have the best secondary
in football it's the best secondary in
football you know when you talk about jc
jackson jonathan jones stefan gilmour
i'd have a hard time finding a better
three than that they can lock down just
about anybody so why wouldn't the
patriots be able to play the same style
of football they played last year which
was play through their defense and do
that except now they have a quarterback
that's capable of making more plays and
really i think a quarterback that fits
more of how their offense is actually
built
and i'm with you mike i don't think it's
that crazy of a thought i'll be shocked
if new england and cam and them are not
a good are not good in some sort of
force in the uh afc
yeah all time
tom brady is far more accomplished
than cam newton yeah no one can argue
that no but when we compare 2019 tom
brady to 2020 cam newton
that's an upgrade sure and and if he
stays healthy that's the key if he stays
healthy the patriots i think will be
there at the end of the day and may in
fact be in the super bowl wouldn't it be
great to have patriots buccaneers oh
that would be unbelievable but one thing
i just have to say this the one thing i
heard consistently
from
people up in new england
is the energy cam newton brings every
day i made a comment to someone up there
about you know when did when did he
establish himself in the quarterback
competition you know when did he kind of
take it over
and i was laughed at almost like as in
like the quarterback competition was
over like the second day cam was in the
building because the whole team
gravitated towards him and his
personality and his charisma and
everything he just became the leader
almost like instantly from that
standpoint and i think that speaks a lot
and i think there is an excitement in
new england about what cam newton's
brought to that locker room and that
football team just a different energy
and the footage that we see on tv now or
on your phone or your tablet wherever
you're watching peacock uh it doesn't do
justice
to
what cam newton really is physically
yeah when you're in his presence he is a
giant he is statuesque he does draw you
in if you're on his team if you're not
on his team you go run
you don't want to mess with cam newton
and and yeah i think that presence i
think everything about him
is something that is going to and you
know we talk about that dynamic of
adrian peterson with the lions and all
the fan boys in the locker room like the
center frank ragnall
wants his autograph and when mike vick
was in the later stages of his career
with all these guys who grew up
following and idolizing mike vick we're
getting into a cut of players getting
into the nfl now who grew up when cam
newton was early in his nfl career and
yeah they're going to be in more awe of
him now they would have been that way
with tom brady too but there's just you
know you you don't miss a beat when it
comes to having that magnetic force in
your locker room and on top of it he's
pretty damn good when he's healthy yeah
no exactly right he's got all those
things he's he's he's you know what a
urban legend you know whatever you want
to say he really is he's that type of
guy
uh that i think young kids all followed
i admire the way you know he plays on
the football field it's different we've
never seen a guy play the position the
way cam newton does never i mean it's
unbelievable all the short yardage runs
the physical contact all of that
and uh of course that's why he was a
little bit beat up but hopefully we'll
get a healthy cam newton and see where
this goes all right so you haven't
picked it yet i mean are you picking the
chiefs to win the super bowl where are
you going i know i'm not doing it till
tomorrow i'm not doing so tomorrow i'm
taking as much time as i possibly can
i'd like to wait until after the super
bowl to be 100 right but they won't let
me do that they want me to do it before
the season starts all right let's look
at the second half of the pft week one
power ranking 17 through 32 again not
much by way of change the derwen james
injury knocks the chargers down a spot
flip flop with the raiders and then i
like what washington has done so much
when they reached rock bottom instead of
continuing to dig
they climbed out of it and i did that
same thing i did when i dropped the
eagles
washington and the jaguars i'll give
washington the edge washington and the
panthers same decision and then finally
washington the giants i popped them up
and i stopped at 29 because i still
think the bengals are going to be better
it's hard when you get to the bottom it
is because i know it's going to it's
going to upset fans because when
everyone part part of what they're
selling now is hope right i get it at
zero and zero anything can happen and
could one of these teams in the low 20s
rise all the way the top yeah sure great
look fine that happens this is a
snapshot of where they are now we're not
saying this is where they're going to be
this isn't a predicted finish this is an
assessment right now of where the 32
teams are and somebody's got to be in
the bottom five and uh you know you can
climb your way out of it or not yeah no
you you can and there's some redeeming
qualities about those teams you see at
the bottom i mean there's things to be
excited about
i just i have a hard time and kristen
could you put that you know the group
the the the uh image back on there i
have a hard time thinking anybody in
that bottom four though can make a
serious move this year i just don't see
how the roster is capable of that now
when you started getting like you know
the lower 20s mike you start talking
about the rams the chargers the raiders
even the bears at 25 you know those are
teams i perk up a little bit and go
there's some potential there that they
could make some serious moves here in
the first few weeks of the year we'll
see where that goes you know the atlanta
falcons at 19 and the browns at 18. you
know they they are intriguing to me as
well
but the browns with all those moving new
parts too new coaches as talented as
they are i don't know i just don't know
if i can get behind it yet i got to see
it
uh but but i think that's the area i
look at to maybe some movers there is
that low 20s area that you got to where
those those teams could be
around dancing around the top 10 maybe
in a few weeks
well one of the teams that has made it
into that upper reaches of the 20s the
jets at number 24. their general manager
hugh douglas
uh doesn't like the fact that people
think joe douglas is going to stink who
did i say hugh douglas yeah he's not
douglas
he's not the generator of the jets and
joe douglas was not a dominant defensive
end uh 10 or 15 years ago joe douglas
the gm of the jets isn't happy that that
people think the team is going to stink
here's douglas from a recent discussion
with reporters
our guys don't live in in a bubble um
we see we see the things that are said
we see the things that are written and
um you know it uh
you know it angers a lot of people um
he's stated
that there's
good players that were on this team last
year that aren't playing this year
um
but you know just going through this
camp
i can tell you that there's some guys on
this team that may not be household
names
but they're good football players
that's joe douglas and you always wonder
not just about what's behind a guy when
he's in a shot like that but what are
the choices that lead to
the head being all the way down here
oh he won we got to get that he wanted
to get a helmet
it's kind of cool we got to get that
emblem in that emblem's cool but there's
got to be a way to do it where you can
get something more than than this i i
don't know i i i like the shot actually
it wasn't that bad i didn't want to see
like his pecs or like you know his his
arm muscles so i'm cool i'd like to at
least confirm that he has a neck okay
can we at least confirm that he has a
neck maybe he doesn't he legitimately
don't seem like bothered though that
they're getting disrespected i think
that's like he was taking it personal
and i think we both agree
that the jets will be a better football
team i love what joe joe douglas and the
jets are in the conversation for winning
the offseason i think you and i are both
defenders of adam gase where we just
don't understand the criticism at times
now the roster is better
but like jets fans don't like go crazy
here all right i mean i i don't think
you're going to the playoffs i think the
thing that scares me is it's going to be
a better football team but mike again
for the second year i worry about the
start of their schedule that's where i
just look at it and go
man
i could sit here and go they could start
out one in three one and four something
like that and when you get to that spot
your season's almost lost you know it's
very few teams that dig yourselves out
of those type of holes but when you go
at buffalo 49ers coming there then you
got to go at to at the colts and then
you got the denver broncos okay that's a
winnable game certainly but those first
three games
i could tell you that i think the jets
are the lesser team on the field no
doubt about it
and and that is a reality the more
losses you pile up early that reduces
your margin for error later in the year
and if you start
one and three one and four
now now look it used to be once you got
the loss number five or lost number six
you had to get very nervous about your
chances of making it to the playoffs now
with seven spots yeah maybe nine and
seven gets you in you still are probably
going to need some help and we've seen
teams that would have been number seven
with 10 wins or 11 wins like the 2008
patriots but but i think that you know
if they if they can weather the storm
early and maybe win a game or two that
they shouldn't yes that's right and and
then they finish like they did last year
see that's the thing there was a time
not that long ago
where
a significant amount of attention was
placed on teams that finished strong and
for the most part teams that finish
strong can carry the momentum over now
one of the reasons i think we've gotten
away from it teams are so fundamentally
different from one year to the next now
so many guys leave yes right and so many
new guys arrive but still the nucleus is
still there for the jets for the most
part it's not like their nucleus has
gotten worse if anything they're nucleus
of players are better better yeah and
they finished six and two last year and
there's something to be said for
finishing six and two
and we've talked about it with the
falcons for some reason i feel like we
give the falcons more of a bump from
their six and two finished then we know
why
right well you know why why is that
i don't know you tell me well because
the falcons have superstar names across
the board right so we look at them and
go damn they got difference makers oh
you know the game plan is not working
good oh oh well julio caught a four-yard
pass and ran for 70. okay screw the game
plan you know oh you know they got todd
gurley and then calvin ridley and then
we know they got some names on defense i
know there's some of them we gotta
they're gonna have to worry about their
health you know that's why atlanta like
if you gave me a team to talk about is
like a if i had to pick like okay you
got a dark horse super bowl team atlanta
would be one of those teams that i think
i'd have on a very short list to go
nobody's talking about it but i think
they're talented enough to be in a super
bowl team but i don't trust it this year
not in the pandemic year not in a team
that we've seen has fallen like flies to
two previous years with injuries i'm not
going to pick this this to be the year
they stay healthy so that scared the the
the death out of me but i at least
that's my two cents there's more
household names on atlanta and in the
jets we're still trying to like joe
douglas said figure out who those guys
are who are those good ball good ball
players that you're talking about that
aren't household names yet that you're
seeing on practice yet well we don't
know we haven't seen that yet we haven't
had preseason football and i think
that's why you're more comfortable with
the falcons than the jets
let me tell you i i breathed a sigh of
relief when you said scared the death
out of me because i've never heard that
saying i've heard scared this something
else out of me and i thought that's
where you were going so thank you
once again for self-editing thyself and
but here's the other side of it too look
i
i have no problem with joe douglas being
upset that people think the jets are
gonna stink good be upset that's one of
the ingredients to getting your locker
room properly motivated and focused go
in there and tell those guys no one
believes in us how many times have we
seen coaches parlay that into the kind
of focus that results in
catching a team that you know like the
bills right out of the gates you know
last year the bills and the jets were
kind of regarded right about
jets were up 16 nothing and they blew it
right this year the bills are here and
the jets are here yeah so maybe maybe
the bills walk into the buzz saw maybe
the bills are a little complacent maybe
the bills are thinking oh it's just the
jets and this is the way to put everyone
on notice right out of the gates that
it's not just the jets
see that we see this every year there
will be the results of several games
this week that make us say
uh oh
we we were wrong about that team now i
always say throughout the first couple
of weeks of the season yeah that's what
still there there will be results that
make us say
maybe we need to go back and revisit
what we thought about that team good bad
or otherwise definitely jets have an
opportunity right out of the gate and
it's good they're pissed off to get
pissed off get focused and go to buffalo
and win you don't have to worry about
fans in the stands go there and get the
win and come home 1-0 and get ready for
the 49ers and if somehow they could pull
off that double bill's
49ers super bowl prediction if you could
somehow pull that off to start the
season all of a sudden the jets are
viewed far more differently than they
are right now yeah they you're right
about that there's no doubt i mean that
would go a long way really even that
opening stretch if they can just you
know come out one and two
two and one that'll go a long way to
changing the frame or the you know the
the mind of the players in the locker
room just the overall thought of the
organization within the organization i
think that's something that you know
would go a long way there jets are a
team to watch out for i just
i can't put my name to it i just can't
not yet i just don't know if there's
enough good players there the defensive
side of the ball i know they were good
last year
i do worry about you know difference
makers on that defense and especially no
longer with jamal adams and you know no
big time pass rusher those are the
things that bother me along with the
afc's you know having a year of studying
greg williams a little bit more and
getting used to what he does there so uh
i think they're a pain in the butt i
just i can't say that i think they're
gonna be a playoff team or anything like
that for that last spot in the afc in
the nfc it is the ultimate crap shoot it
is close your eyes and throw a dart i
may pull a name out of the hat for the
seventh spot in the afc and the nfc it's
wide open it could be any of these teams
except for the jaguars uh and the
bengals uh but other than that the jets
are have as good a chance as anyone else
to steal that last spot and that's
what's going to make this year even more
exciting as we get into december that
race for the last spot that opportunity
to be the team that can go in and upset
the two seed in the wild card round it's
going to be fun it's going to be
exciting and it starts tomorrow night
with texans chiefs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports